as a guy you're actually supposed to
wipe your dick hole yeah after you pee
do you you don't all the time yeah no
you don't i know that was the biggest
lion phase i've ever seen you never done
that wipe your dick
not once
like the little pee after if i'm in nice
clothes i'll give it a wipe
wipe with what
toilet paper really yeah i'll never do
it
never wipe mine i'm feeling really fancy
i'll just use my foreskin and tie it up
like the end of the blue knife oh i
forgot yeah you have you have the
foreskin you have you have the you have
the drip collection no leak no mess
so that's the benefit
yeah yeah you have an oil pan basically
yeah
any residual pee just gets
damn yeah this is a women-friendly
episode for sure dude ladies yeah yeah
tiny meat gang's always been
front-facing for women hey no no we you
it's it's like even yeah 50-50 yeah yeah
down the middle yeah it's it actually
skews a little more to the ladies really
yeah
i would like to apologize first and
foremost
the ladies have the more [ __ ] up sense
of humor yeah they're sick true yeah
well so
our podcast is like 90 10. i always
thought it was because we get a bit
crass but no
maybe it's just cause
we're sexist and i never consider that
that might turn people off yeah that's a
problem is the rampant sexism yeah
how's your podcast it's like killing on
patreon it is doing well i don't know
how has it been fun oh yeah how long's
it been on for now
close to a year nine months [ __ ] yeah i
like this set it's awesome yeah yeah
it's no space but
backyard will do no it's cool yeah no i
really like it how many dudes are on the
podcast four dudes way too many it is
too many dudes that's probably why
only dudes listen to it yeah because
when you get three it's like the middle
ground
and then the fourth it tips it over
yeah then it's all sports well it helps
when you have like a betta cuck
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah it helps when there's like a betta
cup [ __ ]
[Music]
yeah yeah that's actually so interesting
and it's 55 the only thing that i think
has that close of a breakdown for me
would be like tick-tock
where it's like maybe 60 40 and they
haven't discovered that you're sexist
yet no cause i try to hide it yeah and
then it's like i think of myself like
the alt-right youtube pipeline but for
sexism
dude yeah you wean him yeah so you know
twit
yeah most most of your youtube audience
is also mail like yeah it's like it's
like 85 15. damn really yeah huh i think
the stream
might be slightly better like 80 20
but still
definitely male rooted which i think is
also a problem with gaming as a whole
yeah because i think you
had loving parents and never played a
video game girl
yeah oh i played video games did you
yeah
call of duty gears of war okay
i was just an xbox nerd yeah sure yeah
you weren't really playing games yeah i
mean i wasn't like yeah you ever play
starcraft no yes i did actually really i
did play starcraft not like you yeah
thanks thank you
did you play it online and get washed
online by a korean teenager yeah when
would you have when you were developing
a perfect hairline and going to duke
university and
thank you man god
yeah get compliments on this podcast
very often do you not no so it's nice no
it doesn't deserve them yeah yeah
one one once in a while
is nice nah man you're a grown ass man
you've had enough compliments yeah how
old are you
25 40
31 i would guess 35
that's the greatest when you say with
the tone that you would've guessed under
yeah oh no the the shittier way to say
that too is like oh damn so i was over
that old huh how old are you 26. [ __ ]
out of here i like saying it when i know
you're both older
no i'm not i'm 23. so yeah i'm talking
about if i'm in a room with like mr
beast and like a minecrafter then i'm
like 26. yeah got it on my way out
actually you know what that's why i'd
fight in crater class yo dream pull up
[Laughter]
you guys are going to turn graham into a
[ __ ] menace bro yeah
i believe i i believe next time he's
gonna come back just jacked up he
doesn't care he's rich
i know
i i gotta give him credit do you have a
the clip of him like talking about his
fight dude i didn't think he did that
bad i
did pretty much him listening to this
yeah you didn't do that bad like it was
like okay it was like not terrible yeah
it wasn't it wasn't i mean for a dude
who talks about finance all day that's
what i'm saying like i don't think he
actually trained yeah but like on the
same day nobody thought like michael
reeves is not the guy that you think is
gonna beat someone up he's like five
foot two four
ten soaking wet don't sleep on that
pacquiao power man i mean he did have
the pacquiao power but you wouldn't have
thought that from a guy who just make
robot no dude
just make robot all he do is make a
robot and play this one of the top
comments was like it takes
a lot of guts to get in the ring with
someone as crazy as michael and i don't
know michael that much on like a
personal level like that but it seems to
be that the people have known him for a
long time once he commits to doing
something he like pours himself into it
i gave it as much as i could given my
workload but for someone like michael i
mean he'll be as dedicated as he needs
to yeah that's exactly what it seemed
like yeah yeah like he like went like
you know three four times a week would
go to the gym idea you lose at the
creator clash everyone's talking [ __ ] at
you online that sucks
you challenge them you have them all
come to a ring one by one you just beat
the [ __ ] out of your viewers
[Music]
yeah cause they're not trained they
didn't they didn't because even if you
went six months three times a week
you're gonna beat someone who's never
gone yeah you get a ref you just start
walloping out of your fans yeah yeah yes
that's a great idea then it's a
pay-per-view event for your fans more
fans start talking [ __ ]
it's almost like a pyramid of sorts yeah
genius
i love it yeah did you see did you see
his face i don't know we're like talking
about graham stopping way too much but
did you see his face when michael like
connected for the first time yeah his
face was like
oh yeah oh this is real yeah and that
felt way worse than i thought it was
going to i wonder if graham did any
sparring
yeah you get hit in the face when you
spar right
yeah okay okay sorry let me qualify that
sparring like
you know there's like levels of sparring
there's like there's okay let's you know
let's figure out your one two and then
like all right we're gonna go
80 here i feel like you'd be a bad coach
if you sent a guy in and you didn't at
least give him one you know full-on of
but because it's charity i feel like
there would be some degree of like
oh i have to shoot something later so i
don't want to go too hard or you know if
you're gonna box you might as well
[ __ ] box that's what i'm saying
i'm gonna do it let's fight all right
let's fight okay it's on alright go
right and if you win you can have that
[ __ ] back oh
if you win i'll double it
we got gloves dude why don't you each
put one on your
less dominant hand
and we just do like a minute right here
a boxing yeah i don't want a boss right
now
with one hand yeah i just jabs yeah no
and you can only go
like body shots yeah okay okay so yeah
[ __ ] punches in my sternum again yeah
do you know my chest is like an inch
from my heart
it's so close in proximity devastation
so you like literally couldn't i don't
know medically if i'm allowed to i'd
have to do a test they're pretty
rigorous yeah
damn that's actually scary you should
never box i take it back let's do it
let's do it
20 23.
so he could die from a small blow we
should do that
there'd be no greater glory actually
than killing somebody in the room yeah
you would get memed on so hard if you
die
dude people would definitely laugh at
you if you got killed and it's like the
gif of me just falling over yeah he's
schlump he's not even trying hell died
lamou
literally died